正統派です暑くて何もなつけて何もしたくないんですけどもと夏井中でも唯一降り出し
たいことがそれは何かそう
ブレイブレイドこれ新風気軽にならないべきでベイベーだなんですけどまぁおろか思っ
たんですよ
普通マスター闘っちょっとぞ静かに普通のスタジアムで戦うのズーム楽しいんですけど
も特殊なステージでちょっと戦わせてみたいと思ったんですがこの子たちもそれを望ん
でるっ夫ないと特殊なぁスタジアムで試合はできないかと僕は思ったわけなんですよ私
は思った
もちろんの3ジャンルで全部凍っていたら果たしてこいつらはどのように戦った
ただですがこんな辛いのにこのスターズの中を氷次したら果たしてベイブレードず
どうぞトレーナーがどのように戦うのかっていうこと僕疑問に思ったわけです多分子供
また者に水を入れても水が溜まっちゃってう込んでるここだけだと
6コーヒーなっちゃって均等に祝のスタジアムができないと思ったわけでありますそこ
で私何を使うかといいますと
こちら凍っパパッと全体的にヤバいすそれはこちらのローション
[音楽]
髪型になれるんだろう者の尿付のでした者の全体学校均等にローションで水まみれに
なるぐるぐるに入れて結局ローションで凍らせれば通りになるって均等に郡しばくを
張ったスケートリンク札だったスタジアムで英米度をまずと私どのようになるのかって
いうのは某時になりました
ブービーいいかもねこれは非常に伝わりにくいと思いますが結構均等に伸びております
うっに十分じゃあ1回要所でもまあしてみようってローションヌー
こいつさっきまであの動きしてたやつですからね変わるの空イングがをグリップだから
その真っ最中だったからか
[音楽]
この老星をもっと綺麗に広げ4番今いい声だと思いますこれくらいの感じで行き
ましょうではスタジオも冷やしてきます
われ a
結構でかいんだでスタジアムって強いおもちゃ
もうもうもう4
もうやばいプレイトーンスタジアムですこれで冷凍さジャガー s 待って溶ける
溶ける溶ける溶ける溶ける
今津日本は暑いから排斥デモカンジュンに氷でございますもうこれはもう回すしかない
よバリに行くぞ
ていいって言う1号種
ローソンよくわかりませんもうそれを合わせてみましょう午前は知らん
[音楽]
すごいとまぁもうびっくり今の場所は泊まる場所ではなかったぞ
第田中そういう動画じゃありません go 基本的にはあんま変わんないなぁ
ます
tan
とび役になってる2より飛びます何か
car
めちゃくちゃ威力が強いです
めーちゃくちゃぶつかると思いますの札が少ないから使うすっごい跳ねますいやー
すげーこれ
だからそういう動画じゃないって
web
e 7